hello reject nation I'm Greg and I Tara
Ericsson follow her on YouTube and
social media she's funny and pretty what
more could you want from a woman in this
day and age hey Tara
I am half Filipino really in that time
being half Filipino and talking about it
quite a lot in the past few months the
Filipino fanbase has grown a lot on this
channel okay yes it is our number four
or third country of most subscribers for
the real rejects in the Philippine yeah
how cool and normally want to check out
videos from the requests from the people
in the Philippines are like these really
emotional commercials for a while now
this video specifically has been
requested and I haven't seen it but for
a while they've been asking to check it
out eight days in the Philippines and
eight men oh my god sounds great and
everything Philippines let's do it
afterwards I would share with you my
story of going into Philippines when I
was three years old but first let's
watch you remember is none of it okay
yeah the whole video I'm going to be
like coming to a [ __ ] in my episode
sure so I'm traveling today to this
country called the Philippines and the
country tagline is it's more fun in the
Philippines
[Music]
for 2015 if you're not in the car the
whole time the Philippines let me
connect random people smell I want to
see if I can have food water shelter for
the whole day for 0.0 dollars here in
Manila
NOAA my family and my entire wallet and
check down the hotel industry is very
domestic Muslims more taxes I do not eat
out but what I can do is rely on
people's generosity for water exam
thirsty
[Music]
from food exam off my wallet at least
did you an extra you're lying to a bunch
of old he ran after them whoa but for
shelter this is a big heart I stand
ready and one two three four five six
seven people and then I beat this guy he
nicked me and bite me food offered me at
home
this means Ben it doesn't even want to
be filmed they're still good in this
world that's limited money
I don't like Phineas that's why I like
the Philippines it's very cheap a fool
detour at this island oh this one
I hear them for $70 at Montcalm he'll
even get the Wonder horse will cost you
300 good - [ __ ] you back haha
everything with me - you might like
doing a street
he can't even Sufis empty row broken
story bottom cook it's a whole village
that is in the park with two cops
building you see holy crap holy moly
Bella
he never drink ut3 you can be friendly
locals because the old sea oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
but watching from your phone you will
get bored for five seconds
so they tell you amazing incredible
above water is headed earth even when
there is no Sun it's not just what's
above water is on the one will be also
tight underneath your baby's illness
formation love you and the gigantic fish
that does not give a damn
[Music]
oh man I never wanted to go back to the
Philippines for the net
[Music]
[ __ ] structure at 2453 metres on which a
six-pack percent of her sister Mount
Fuji Japan and three times that of
course Khalifa Wow not appearance and
height then nature so rejecting it's her
personality man inside she's so shy she
hides behind the clouds all the time in
fact some say her husband's on the class
and when you fire receivers she
beautiful turns erupts every three to
five here that's what I say about myself
a masterful she's perfect the most
perfect human nature that to offer that
may upset one in it sees one for the
past five minutes mo estate in the
richest parks the Philippine it so easy
for me to believe that all the
Philippines looks like this
okay God is not only one camp right away
from here your life cute and the trash
Mountain check it as for people with in
such extreme poverty the air is on one
with of smell but even just this area
25% of the Philippines slip under the
poverty line it's incredible that under
the scheme Peru you can launch my [ __ ]
and dinner like this green stuff going
the ground meat it's beautiful nature in
this scene it means there's so much
trash pile the top of each other they
form a mountain where actual people live
and land on the ground the country's
tagline is it's more fun in the
Philippines so I think a more
appropriate one is it's more fun in 75
grams of the Philippine I'm gonna say it
again
the filthy is cheap which means you need
many dollars to come here and see this
piece of you but it also means you need
may dollars to help those that need help
it's so cheap in here that we can buy
this burger
we need all four 26 26 never exact price
you can buy a salary will be further
without breaking the bank and in a place
where people are so good the trash
former so now no I can form and show
mountain of food for the price of one
hotel stage in your city whoa really
and with that you can feed up to 8,000
people I'll have you so cool to do yes
she tried to meet back to Racine but
it's also need
system to help those in need in my last
day how to compete I'm sad but here is
everything that I write about in filter
it's a country with more than 7,000
islands between this and this and I rent
out this volcano this smoking older with
the tires they're so cheap you can get a
hold of drunk or another poor village
bag without breaking the bank
but we are using sub box Paul research
three people in the top of a trash
Mountain or at radio with a head but you
can move the world up what you can
improve on whatever other people they
will be generous they will feed you and
they were forced you have known it will
simply start and they will probably like
crazy respectable there will be your
friends real friends the countryside
line is it's more fun in the Philippines
I don't mind in Venice there for love
and up it would be that's one
[Music]
hell yeah yeah there'll be a real friend
dude that was crazy I I feel so out of
touch with my people I had no idea that
is all that's hard at it at day four
whoo that was rough that's so cool that
night five or six the poverty when
you're talking about yeah what was like
after day four day five it started right
where you actually to do you're like oh
my god but damn like would I kid I could
be trying to be like a Filipino PT feed
some kids some burgers yeah but first
you got it partied up right get a build
is drunk get a village drunk daddy fun
oh I love that rum coke and run though
headache status yeah but who cares your
party little much Filipino doing karaoke
all night oh yeah
selfie that'd be so much ok so here's an
I went to the Philip yes tell me
was three years old my grandmother would
babysit me mmm-hmm and my grandmother
had to go to the Philippines of three
months and they thought it would be
cheaper to send me to the Philippines of
my grandma then higher babysitter so on
the way the airport my parents said
we'll meet you on the plane
thousands of thought a little way oh my
goodness really beans with my grandma I
came back to eat the guy look I came
back speaking Tagalog I forgot every
word of it because my family except for
my mom she didn't bother to keep
speaking to me into God Hey but I
remember single damn thing whatever I
did my first memory Gillian
my first memory ever is me coming back
to the airport and talking to my brother
about 300 to red when I came back that's
what he wanted to catch of me when you
were still three uh yeah like three when
I came back
Wow yeah my first memories walking be
remember talking about Street Fighter 2
he's not asking me about Philippines it
was like I got the video camera super
Nintendos
a
wanted to go to the Philippines but this
makes me go I should seriously plan a
trip gotta go to the Philippines the
full pot you got to go to the
Philippines that's where your roots are
yeah your roots are there Greg you're
ready to go to Italy okay Alba yeah cuz
I'm half Italian
my mom lent her a while a couple of
years ago my sister I just didn't know
you can live a life like that out there
everything's so affordable yeah that's
insane that's like father said that's
like baller yeah we'd be booking can be
rolling in the dog eating nice dinner oh
[ __ ] romantic date for 15 bucks oh man I
could go on like three romantic dates
every day oh dude amazing breakfast
lunch there's are all going to be
romantic cuz I got the money for it and
if I go to the Philippines I could meet
you guys to God I want to do the poverty
just smile and write you know how many
times I'm walking down the street and
like people are just like mostly
homeless people who are very nice and
I'll walk up and they're like you should
smile smiles because like I have a I
have a you know [ __ ] resting face so
when I'm walking and then there must
like smile and I'm just like yeah I know
like but I don't really ever do it you
have a nice smile though yeah it's
alright I sometimes oh okay and then I
hear you know dollar takes on my food
your real smiles are knives my real
smile but realize get frankly not this
one yeah not bad you know thing is lunch
guys when you really smile yeah really
nice fun that's a compliment
learn to take it she in Filipino she
don't understand what compliment so
close my file
okay well if I go to the Philippines I'm
going to visit mountain trash or
whatever you called it miniaturize round
open I'm definitely going to mountain
trying to find a nice manner to trash
that $100 soon as storage is America
build our own trash Mountain we should
right because then like trees grow in it
and then we could live it it's a good
hashtag property that nobody cares about
in LA until I'm like boom this is where
I live and they're like what and I'm
like it's a mountain of trash and I'm
like oh I don't want it but then I'm
like but I live here and then it's like
wow cheap rent I looked at it in a trash
on my dad was a hoarder Italian hoorah
we all suck in Bolivia in Florida right
now oh I can't
no no no no no no no Porter's calm or
wait what's the TV show you guys need to
be on that candy showers there's gum ah
ah that's the name of the TV show it's
not it's like now if you if you actually
watch boxes to get out to get to get to
the bathroom or like was hard to get to
the back it's a lot of squeezing around
oh my god that's insane yeah my dad was
if I what I didn't know there was a term
from where I live until I saw the show
hoarders in my hoarder home and I was
like hey I have a home just like this -
yeah Wow crazy huh that's insane I know
so I hit him well on trash middle or
wherever they go little bit after
happened subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification valtira eric and
the lovely of funny Tara here comes Tara
Ericsson YouTube channel go check her
out
follow her on social media hashtag this
idiot yeah goodbye
Filipinos and the rest of the nation or
world that is lucky I need a double a
dis double thing I do goodbye may go
you